Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a short Drama film called “The Boy with a
Camera for a Face”. Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we are shown a
broken TV. The camera zooms into it and leads us
to the day the protagonist is born. The doctors
and nurses surround his mother, urging her to
push harder while the father sits at the other
side with a camera. He believes that he is going
to capture a beautiful moment, but what happens
next makes him put the camera away in confusion.
Even the nurses and the doctor share the same look
of confusion as they pass the newborn baby around.
When the mother gets to hold her baby, she doesn’t
know what to think of it because the newborn has
a camera for a face. He involuntarily records
the birth from the other side as a normal camera
would. The doctors go crazy trying to figure out
how this is possible. They stare at the sonogram
for hours but do not seem to find the reason for
the baby not having a face. They try to pass it up
as genetics but no camera genes are found in the
parents. With time, they get frustrated and start
blaming the mother for sleeping with a camera.
The husband accuses his wife of cheating. She is
left alone with her child and doesn’t know if she
can ever love him as a human if he becomes the
reason for their divorce. But her worries fade
away when the doctors claim he is in fact the
husband's kid. They also admit that they do not
know the cause behind his head being a camera. But
they have found out that to keep the child alive,
they should put a blank tape in the slot
on his back. It must be done every night,
without fail to prevent heart failure. The blank
tapes mean that the kid is bound to record every
moment of his life even if he doesn’t want to.
The doctor inserts the Day one’s tape on his back
and sends the camera boy home with his parents.
By now, the parents have accepted him as he is,
because no matter the face, he will always be
their child. As the camera boy grows older,
he starts to take pictures on command. One
day, when trying to take a family photo,
the parents cannot seem to get good lighting.
Hence, they hold the object camera and make
their son click pictures. They have finally
found a use for him that only he is good at.
Every night, they would change the boy’s tape
and put it in the cupboard safely. At first,
they are delighted that because of the tapes, he
will remember every moment in his life. But what
the parents fail to register is that a lifetime's
worth of tapes requires a lifetime to watch.
The cupboard soon starts to fill up with tapes
and memories that are of no use to him. Soon,
the camera boy grows old enough to go to school.
Even though he has no expression on his face,
we can tell he is nervous. Everyone looks at him
differently for obvious reasons. The kids start
to bully him, pushing him around, calling him
camera head, and telling him he should be dead.
But they forget that the boy’s memory is
photographic. When his mother sees the tape
at the end of the day, she fumes in anger. She
visits the principal’s office the very next day
and shows him the video. With clear evidence, the
bullies have no way to defend themselves. They
are punished for their actions and starting that
day, they stop bothering the camera boy. However,
they move on to bullying another kid, calling
him fat and telling him to kill himself.
The camera boy watches them in fear, unknowingly
recording them. The tape yet again makes it to the
principal’s office and the bullies are taught a
lesson. As time goes by and the camera boy learns
to socialize, he makes a lot of friends. His
uniqueness attracts people towards him but with
the attention also comes drawbacks. His friends,
even the closest ones, often treat him like he is
only a camera. Soon, like any normal teenager, the
camera boy falls in love with a beautiful girl.
They go on dinner dates, talk about different
things, and seem to get along well. Until one day,
when they are in bed and things start to get
steamy. The camera boy tries undressing her,
but she suddenly realizes that he is
filming everything. She pushes him away,
calling him a pervert for something he has no
control over. The boy offers to put a lens cap on
but the girl asks him to get out of her room.
She never talks to him again, leaving him
heartbroken. He starts to think that he will
never find true love because of his face.
Starting that day, his life goes downhill. He
is never let inside a movie hall because of the
no-camera policy. Moreover, his father throws the
house TV away because the boy watching it would be
considered piracy. He gets depressed and refuses
to go outside but even at home, he has nothing to
do. He starts to get bored and lonely, cursing
his fate for making him unique. That is, until
one day when his life changes. While walking down
a road, he comes across a girl. Weirdly enough,
her face is unfocused from his point of view. He
tries moving his lenses in different positions
but cannot seem to see her features. He doesn’t
know the reason for the weird phenomenon but it
doesn’t bother him. The girl becomes his
friend and with time, they fall in love.
Since he cannot see her face, she doesn’t mind
getting naked in front of him. It is almost as if
God sensed he was depressed and sent her just for
him. The two have been dating for quite some time
when one day, a man approaches them. He turns out
to be a producer who wants to make a show out of
the camera boy’s life. He wants the boy to hand
in all of the tapes that he has filmed till now so
they can create a several episode show with less
budget. Handing in all the tapes means that they
should give up the tapes of them making love.
The couple is reluctant at first but they agree
to be a part of it when given a briefcase
full of money. The show hits the television
and instantly becomes a success. The couple
gains millions of fans in only a few days.
They turn into celebrities and are swarmed by
paparazzi everywhere they go. With the money,
they buy a brand new house together. As the show’s
popularity increases, the camera boy is given his
own channel where people would have to pay
to see his life on live television. He soon
asks his girlfriend to be his wife. That part of
their life is also broadcasted live to the world.
They have no privacy at all but it is the least of
their concern because the show’s ratings skyrocket
after he proposes to her. They get married
as the world watches, happy for the couple.
Then, something that had never crossed the camera
boy’s mind happens. People become addicted to his
show, so much so that the entire nation stays
indoors watching his life twenty-four seven. It
is almost as if he is the only living person
and all others are living life through him.
When he and his wife get bored of such a lonely
life, they return to his childhood home. As soon
as he opens the door, the piles of tapes of his
life come into his view. The house barely has
any space for furniture because of the tapes.
The boy goes to the first closet of the tapes
and stares at them, reminiscing about his
childhood and thinking of how far he has come.
Then, he goes to the living room to see that his
wife is in front of the TV. She, like the others,
has been addicted to watching the show.
He tries to switch the TV off but nothing
happens. He calls the wife, trying to wake her
up but she stays staring at the television.
The boy sheds a single tear and finally realizes
that the only way to wake up the entire country
is to stop the live streaming show. So, he brings
out the first tape of his life that was ever
recorded. He plays the tape on TV while in the
bathtub. People who are watching the live stream
also get to witness his birth through the video.
Everyone holds their breaths as the boy puts
the TV into the tub, electrocuting himself. He
dies while watching the video of his birth.
The live show finally ends with his death and
people register how obsessed they had gotten. They
go out and enjoy their lives like they did before
the show. His wife is at a park, heartbroken
by his death. Yet, she is happy that people,
including herself, have come back to their senses.
The movie ends as she watches a man and his kids
playing in the park and taking a picture together.
The camera reminds her of her late husband.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.